The five key data standards we will now discuss are
international classification of diseases, or ICD-10,
current procedural terminology (CPT ),
logical observation identifiers names and codes(LOINC),
national drug code (NDC),
and systematized nomenclature for medicine (SNOMED).
ICD and CPT are widely used in the US because in most cases,
they are required for medical billing.
CPT and NDC are US-specific.
There are classifications although CPT increasingly has
sub-codes to provide more details about a procedure for more precise billing.
LOINC is not quite an ontology,
or provides significant details about clinical tests,
and is in use internationally.
ICD-10 and SNOMED are internationally used ontologies
capable of representing clinical relationships among their elements.
When we discuss fire later on,
you will see that it builds on these data standards
and fire resources specifically reference them.